hi there today we're looking at
attention is all you need by Google just
to declare I don't work for Google just
because we've been looking at Google
papers lately but it's just an
interesting paper and we're gonna see
what's the deal with it so basically
what the authors are saying is we should
kind of get away from basically onions
so traditionally what you would do and
these authors particular interested in
NLP natural language processing so
traditionally when you had like a
language task the cat eats the mouse and
you would like to translate this to say
any other language like let's say German
or whatever what you would do is you
would try to encode this sentence into a
representation and then decode it again
so somehow somehow this sentence needs
to all go into say one vector and then
this one vector needs to somehow be
transformed into the target language so
these are tradition called sack to sack
tasks and they have been solved so far
using recurrent neural networks you
might know the Alice TN networks that
are very popular for these tasks what
basically happens in an RNN is that you
go over the say source sentence here one
by one here you take the word the you
kind of encode it maybe with a word
vector if you know that is so you turn
it into like a vector a word vector and
then you use a neural network to turn
this vector into what we call a hidden
state so this H 0 is a hidden state you
then take the second token here cat you
again take it
world vector because need to represent
it with numbers somehow so you use word
vectors for that you turn this into you
put it through the same function so here
is what it's like a little easy for
encoder turn into the same function but
this time this hidden state also gets
plugged in here so the word vector did
instead you can actually think of having
like a started state here a start
usually people either learn this or just
initialize with zeros that kind of goes
in to the encoder function so it's
always really the same function and from
the previous hidden state and the
current word vector the encoder again
predicts another hidden state h1 and so
on so you take the next token you turn
it into a word vector you put it through
this thing the encoder function and of
course this is a lot more complicated in
actual like say an LST M that's the
basic principle behind it so you you end
up with H 2 and here you'd have H 3 H 4
and the last hidden state H 4 here you
would use this in kind of exactly the
same fashion you plug it into like a
decoder let the decoder which would
output you a word D and it would also
output you a next hidden state so H 5
let's say let's just go on with the with
the listing of the states and this H 5
would again go into the decoder which
would output concert like so that's how
you would decode you basically these are
n ends what they do is they kind of take
if you look on top here they take an
input a current input and they take the
last hidden state and they compute a new
hidden state in the case of the decoder
they take the hidden state and they take
kind of
the previous usually the previous word
that you output you also feed this back
into the decoder and they will output
the next word kind of make sense so you
would guess that the hidden state kind
of encode what the sentence means and
the last word that you output you need
this because maybe for grammar right you
know what you've just output so kind of
the next word should be based on that
of course you don't have to have to do
it exactly this way but that's kind of
what what is orleans did so attention is
a mechanism here to basically increase
the performance of the orleans so the
tension would do is in in this
particular case if we look at the
decoder here if it's trying to predict
this word for cat then or the next word
here say here it wants the next word and
[Music]
in essence the only the only h6 the only
information it really has is what the
last word was german word for cat and
what the hidden state is so if we look
at what word it actually should output
in the input sentence it's this here
eats right and if we look at kind of the
the information flow that this word has
to travel so first it needs to encode
into a word vector it needs to go
through this encoder that's the same
function for all the words so nothing
specific and we learned to the word eats
here all right let's go through this
hidden state traverse again into another
step this hidden state because we have
two more tokens and then the next state
state then it goes all the way to the
decoder where the first two words are
decoded and still so this H six this
hidden state somehow still needs to
retain the information that now the
it's somehow is kind of their world to
be translated and that they that the
decoder should find the German word for
that so that's that's of course very a
very long path or there's a lot of
transformations involved over these all
of these hidden states and the hidden
states not only do they need to remember
this particular word but all of the
words and the order and so on and the
grammar Norquay the grammar you can
actually learn with the decoders
themselves but kind of the meaning and
the structure of the sentence so it's
very hard for an RNN to learn all of
this what they what we call long-range
dependencies and so naturally you
actually think well why can't we just
you know decode the first word to the
first word the second word to the second
world it actually works pretty well in
this example right like the the cat cuts
it eats the week just decoded it one by
one about of course that's not how
translation works in translations the
sentences can become rearranged in the
target language like one word can become
many words or you could even be an
entirely different expression so
attention is a mechanism by which this
decoder here in this step that we're
looking at can actually decide to go
back and look at particular parts of the
input especially what it would do
anything like popular attention
mechanisms is that the dis decoder here
would can decide to attend to the hidden
states of the input sentence what that
means is in in this particular case we
would like to teach the decoder somehow
that AHA look here I need to pay close
attention to this step here because that
was the step when the word eats was just
encoded so it probably has a lot of
information about what I would like to
do right now namely translate this word
eats so this mechanism
if you look at the information flow it
simply it goes through this word vector
goes through one encoding step and then
is that hidden state and then the
decoder can look directly at that so the
the path length of information is much
shorter than going through all the
hidden states in a traditional way so
that's where tension helps and the way
that the decoder decides what to look at
is like a kind of an addressing scheme
you may know it from neural turing
machines or or kind of other other kind
of neural algorithms things so what the
decoder will do is in each step it would
output a bunch of keys oops sorry about
that that's my hand being trippy so what
I would output is a bunch of keys so K 1
through K and what would these keys
would do is they would index these
hidden kind of hidden states via a kind
of softmax architecture and we're gonna
look at this I think in the actual paper
we're discussing because it's gonna
become more clear which is kind of
notice that the decoder here can decide
to attend it to the input sentence and
kind of draw information directly from
there instead of having to go just to
the hidden state it's provided with so
if we go to the paper here what do these
authors propose and the thing is they
teach the origins they basically say
attention is all you need you don't need
the entire recurrent things basically in
every step of this decode of this and
basically of the decoding so you want to
produce the target sentence so in this
step in this step in this step you can
basically you don't need the recurrence
even just kind of do attention over
everything and you
be fine namely what they do is they
propose this transformer architecture so
what does it do it has two parts what's
what's called an encoder and a decoder
but don't kind of be confused um because
this all happens at once so this is not
an art and it all happens at once every
all the source sentence so if we again
have the cat oops that doesn't work as
easy let's just do this this is a source
sentence and then we also have a target
sentence that maybe we've produced two
words and we want to produce this third
word here what a produces so we would
feed the entire source sentence and also
the targets and as we produced so far to
this network namely the source sentence
would go into this part and the target
that we've produced so far would go into
this part and this is the all combined
and at the end we get an output here at
the output probabilities that kind of
tells us the probabilities for the next
word so we can choose the top
probability and then repeat the entire
process so basically every step in
production is one training sample every
step in producing a sentence here before
with the Orang ends the entire sentence
to sentence translation is one sample
because we need to back propagate
through all of these RNA in steps
because they all happen kind of in
sequence here basically output of one
single token is one sample and then the
computation is finished the back drop
happens through everything only for this
one step there is no multi-step kind of
back propagation as in Orland and this
is kind of a paradigm shift in sequence
processing because people were always
convinced that you kind of need these
recurrent things in order to
to make good to learn these dependencies
but here they basically say Nenana
we can just do attention over everything
and little bit will actually be fine if
we just do one step projections so let's
go one by one so here with an input
embedding and say an output embedding
these these are symmetrical so basically
the tokens just get embedded with say
word vectors again then there's a
positional encoding this is kind of a
special thing where because you know
lose this kind of sequence nature of
your algorithm you kind of need to
encode where the words are that you push
through the network so the network kind
of goes AHA this is a word at the
beginning of the sentence or is the word
towards the end of the sentence so or
that it can compare to words like which
one comes first
which one comes second and you do this
it's pretty easy for the networks if you
do it with kind of these trigonometric
functioning embeddings so if I draw your
sine wave and I don't need a sine wave
of that a stop was fast and I draw you a
sine wave that is even faster maybe this
one actually sync one two three four
five doesn't matter you know what I mean
so I can encode the first world you can
encode the first position with all down
and then the second position is kind of
down down up and the third position is
kind of up down up and so on so this is
kind of a continuous way of binary
encoding of position so if I want to
compare two words I can just look at all
the scales of these things and I know
how this word one word has high here and
the other word is low here so they must
be pretty far away like one must be at
the beginning and one must be at the end
if they happen to match in this long
rate long wave and they also are both
kind of low in this wave and then I can
look in this way for like oh maybe
they're close together but here
I really got the information which ones
first which was second so these are kind
of positional encodings they they're not
critical to this algorithm but they just
encode where the words are which of
course that is important and it gives
the networking a significant boost in
performance but it's not like it's not
that the meat of the thing the meat of
the thing is that now that these
encoding is go into the network's they
simply do what they call tension here
attention here and attention here so
there's kind of three kinds of attention
so basically the first attention on the
bottom left is simply attention as you
can see over the input sentence so if I
told you before you need to take this
input sentence if you look over here and
you somehow need to encode it into a
hidden representation and this now looks
much more like the picture I drew here
in the picture I drew right at the
beginning is that all at once I kind of
put together this head representation
and all you do is he used attention over
the input sequence which basically means
you kind of pick and choose which word
you look at more or less so with the
bottom right so in the the output
sentence that you've produced so for
example a encoded into kind of a hidden
state and then the third on the top
right that's the I think that sorry I
got interrupted so as are saying the top
right is the most interesting part of
the attention mechanism here where
basically it unites the kind of encoder
part with the kind of beak let's not it
combines the source sentence with the
target sentence that you've produced so
far so as you can see maybe here I can
just slightly annoying but I'm just
gonna remove these kind of circles here
so
if you can see here there is an output
going from the part that encodes the
source sentence and it goes into this
multi-head attention there's two
connections and there's also one
connection coming from the encoded
output so far here and so there's three
connections going in going into this and
we're gonna take a look at what these
three connections are so the the three
connections here basically are the keys
values and queries if you see here the
values and the keys are what is output
by the encoding part of the source
sentence and the query is output by the
encoding part of the target sentence and
these are not only one value key in
query so there are many and this kind of
multi-head attention fashion so there
are just many of them instead of one but
you can think of and as there's just
kind of sets so the attention computed
here is what does it do so first of all
it calculates a adult product of the
keys and the queries and then it is a
soft max over this and then it
multiplies it by the value so what does
this do if you thought product the keys
and the queries what you would get is so
as you know if you have two vectors and
the dot there dot product basically
gives you the angle between the vectors
with especially in high dimensions most
vectors going to be of kind of a 90
degree kind of I know the Americans
doodle the little square
so most vectors are going to be not
aligned very well so their dot product
will kind of be zero ish but if a key in
the query actually aligned with each
other like
if they point into the same directions
the dot product will actually be large
so what you can think of this as the the
keys are kind of here the keys are just
a bunch of vectors in space and each key
has an Associated value so each key
there is a kind of a table value one
value to value three this is really
annoying if I do this over text right so
again here so we have a bunch of keys
right in space and with a table with
values and each key here corresponds to
a value value one value to value three
value 4 and so each key is associated
with one of these values and then when
we introduce a query what can it do so
query will be a vector like this and we
simply compute D so this is Q this is
the query we compute the dot product
with each of the keys and and then we
compute a softmax over this which means
that one key will basically be selected
so in this case it would be probably
this blue key here that has the biggest
dot product with the query so this is
key to in this in this case and the
softmax so if you if you don't know what
a softmax is you have you have like X 1
2 X and B like some numbers then you
simply do you map them to the
exponential function each one of them
and but also each one of them you divide
by the sum of over over I of e to the X
I so basically and this is a
renormalization basically you you do the
exponential function of the numbers
which of course this makes the kind of
big numbers even bigger so basically
what you end up with is one of these
numbers x1 through xn will become very
big compared to the others
and then you renormalize so basically
one of them will be almost one and the
other ones will be almost zero simply
the the maximum function you can think
of in a differentiable way I mean it
should just want to select the biggest
entry in this case here we kind of
select the key that aligns most with the
query which in this case would be key
too and then we when we multiply this
softmax thing with the with the values
so this query this this inner product if
we multiply Q with K to as an inner
product and we take the softmax over it
softmax what we'll do is i'm going to
draw it upwards here we're going to
induce a distribution like this and if
we multiply this by the value it will
basically select value two so this is
this is kind of an indexing scheme into
this memory of values and this is what
then the network uses to compute further
things using so you see the output here
goes into kind of more layers of the
neural network upwards so basically what
what you can think what does this mean
you can think of here's the whoops deep
I want to delete this you can think of
this as basically the encoder of the
source sentence right here discovers
interesting things that looks ugly it
discovers interesting things about the
about the source sentence and it builds
key value pairs and then the encoder of
the target sentence builds the queries
and together they give you kind of the
next the next signal so it means that
the network basically says here's a
bunch of things here is a here's a bunch
of things about the source sentence
that you might find interesting that's
the values and the keys are ways to
index the values so it says here's a
bunch of things that are interesting
which are the values and here is how you
would address these things which is the
keys and then the other part of the
network builds the queries it says I
would like to know certain things so
think of the value is like attributes
like here is the name and the the kind
of tallness and the weight of a person
right and the keys are like that the
actual index is like name height weight
and then the other part of the network
can decide what I want I actually want
the name so my query is the name it will
be aligned with the key name and the
corresponding value would be the name of
the person you would like to describe so
that's how kind of these networks work
together and I think it's a it's a
pretty ingenious it's not entirely new
because it has been done of course
before with all the differentiable
Turing machines and whatnot but it's
pretty cool that this actually works and
actually works kind of better than our
it ends if you simply do this so they
describe a bunch of other things here I
I don't think they're too important
basically that the point they make about
this attention is that it reduces path
lengths and kind of that's the the main
reason why it should work better with
this entire attention mechanism you
reduce the amount of computation steps
that information has to flow from one
point in the network to another and that
what brings the major improvement
because all the computation steps can
make you lose information and you don't
want that you want short path lengths
and so that's that's what this method
achieves and they claim that's why it's
better and it works so well so they have
experiments you can look at them they're
really good at everything of course of
course you're always have state of the
art and I think I will conclude here if
you want to check it out yourself
they have extensive code on github where
you can build your own transformer
networks and with that have a nice day
and see ya